nous sommes au poste frontière de maggie
loft badil ski et les gens font quelques
dernières provisions avant d'aller en
moldavie ce n'est pas le point d'entrée
privilégié des ukrainiens et pourtant
vous pouvez le voir beaucoup d'attentes
beaucoup de voitures environ des
dizaines de milliers de personnes sont
passées ici ces derniers temps pour fuir
les combats au poste-frontière les
soldats empêchent tous les ukrainiens en
âge de combattre de quitter le pays car
il faut des hommes au front
hier j'ai fait passer ma famille en
moldavie et moi je vais devoir repartir
a donné pro je domine
je dois attendre qu'on m'emmène combat à
transmettre
ma famille s'est vendu cette année en
roumanie en allemagne eh ben ils vont
essayer d'avoir le statut de respect pas
aux chutes
quant aux idées vers notre ville on n'y
avait pas très bas il y en avait
beaucoup juste à côté à quartier les
russes nous bombarde
et frappe même ceux qui sont dans leur
maison et dans les abris
sur le pont qui sépare les deux pays
beaucoup d'émotion avec des familles en
pleurs alors qu'elles doivent laisser
des maris ou des frères derrière en
ukraine désormais c'est une nouvelle vie
pour elle ici en moldavie beaucoup nous
disent qu'elles ne savent pas où elles
iront si elles iront roumanie ou dans
d'autres pays en europe si c'est
possible la moldavie un des pays les
plus pauvres du continent européen
accepte les réfugiés mais demandent de
l'aide de la communauté internationale